[Musique]
les olympiques c'est ce qu'on a toujours
rêvé c'est de donner un futur justement
à nos enfants
depuis quelques jours c'est
l'effervescence dans le monde du hip hop
et les entraînements double d'intensité
il faut dire que l'annoncent d'un break
dance olympique il ya un peu bousculé ce
monde qui vient de la rue le professeur
de break dance au centre d'éducation aux
adultes dans la petite bourgogne jonas
alias oméga tron nous parle des défis du
breakdance
c'est dans les années 80 quel monde ils
ont commencé à boire
cette danse qui sort de la rue qui que
tu vois ça ça demande des mouvements de
corps qu'elles soient voir qu'ils sont
très dynamiques et aussi qu'ils sont
rythmique qui vont avec la musique est
spectaculaire
c'est sûr qu'il ya la culture mais à
l'intérieur de nous on s'entraîne paraît
comme un athlète la nutrition on
s'assure aussi que on garde une une
comme un bon condition physique je pense
que ça faisait un bout que ça se tramait
que c'était dans l'air que le breakdance
était à l'ordre du jour pour le comité
olympique
on va avoir de la visibilité que ça va
peut-être amener plus d'adhérents de
pratiquer cette danse mais d'un autre
côté je vous envoie aussi les régimes
capitalistes qui viennent un peu
s'approprier la culture
puis et puis nous la revendre un peu
comme ils nous vendent ce qui est
équitable et bio et au goût du jour
oppose la porte je trouve que trois je
trouvais ça bien qu'on puisse se
reconnaître que un art de la rue ça peut
être à la fois ça peut finir au niveau
au niveau qu'en pratique
cuisine moins de choses qu'on puisse
renaître le côté athlétique de cet art
le break dance a fait sa première
apparition aux jeux de la jeunesse à
buenos aires en 2018 il faudra cependant
attendre décembre 2020 pour connaître la
décision finale
si le sport est choisi par les vieux
bonzes du cio ce serait à vent de
fraîcheur dans une maison qui a bien
besoin de rajeunissement tôt mercredi
radio-canada à montréal
[Musique]